prospect of proof coming from the Miller
investigation on any collusion may never
see the light of day that's long been
normalized by pundits but now the shroud
of secrecy around the renowned Russia
probe is darkening further election
meddling evidence could be out of reach
even for the defense the United States
of America respectfully opposes the
motion of defendant Concord management
and Consulting LLC for approval to
disclose documents identified by the
special counsel as sensitive for purpose
of preparing for trial the defendant
this time is Concord management and
consulting a firm managed by yevgeniy
pre Gorshin a Russian multi-millionaire
nicknamed Putin's chef for his catering
commitments to the Kremlin Mulla accuses
him of being the chieftain of Russian
online trolls who allegedly played a
role in swaying the 2016 election in
response his company hide a law firm in
the US as you would but apparently some
of the private information the lawyers
had previously received from Muller
emerged online for all to see it was
published on Twitter by the account
hacking redstone which has then been
suspended a representative of the online
file-sharing portal has confirmed to the
FBI that the specific account used to
publish the matching discovery materials
was registered on October the 19th 2018
by a user with an IP address that
resolves to Russia but a screenshot of
the tweet allegedly showed the law firm
had been hacked so apparently the
attorneys had nothing to do with it it's
not like they would voluntarily leaked
classified information why well because
well because they can that's why and
well some outlets sent this unique
bandwagon crashing down the hill this
company went and hired a Pittsburgh law
firm and was and has managed to
essentially draw this out and use
essentially the legal system of the
United State
against the Muller investigation so in
history's parade of a myriad of court
cases where defendants would hire
lawyers to well defend themselves
against the accusations they pleaded not
guilty to this one somehow stands out
and what standard procedure in every
single other case is using the legal
system and this one but Miller is
totally cool with it now he has a
perfectly good reason to deny the
defense access to court materials which
is any prosecutors dream come true
Nullah says he will only show the case
docs to pre gordon himself but making
someone who will never come to the u.s.
to face these supposed charges and
arrest
dream on that is a problem of Conchords
own making so how the tide has turned
now anyone salivating in anticipation of
juicy collusion details might be better
off waiting for russian hackers yoshida
knows they're illegal analysts Lionel to
say that prosecutors are normally eager
to share evidence there is a concept of
disclosing information which tends to be
exculpatory meaning information which
tends to work to your defense a
prosecutor must always provide
information evidence to let you know the
defendant what you're being charged with
and what you can do to interpose a
defense the only time a prosecutor wants
to hide information from you is that if
the information doesn't help the
prosecutor if there's something that
hurts the prosecutor I was a prosecutor
we love to show you evidence of what we
have against you we want you to know
everything that we have so that you
think wow they've got me now so why is
he doing this because either a he
doesn't have any evidence B there's
something embarrassing he doesn't want
you to see or see all of the above
you